สอน
ครับ
สวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะคุณเป็นใครคะเนี่ย
ผมชื่อปีเตอร์โฮมหรือว่าครูโฮม
นะครับ
ตอนนี้เรียมก็อยู่กับครูโฮมนะคะทุกคนตอน
นี้ครูโฮมอยู่ที่ไหนคะ
ผมอยู่ที่บ้านครับที่กรุงเทพฯครับ
[เพลง]
ก่อนหน้านี้ก่อนที่เรียนจะมาคุยกับครูโฮม
เราก็กำลังทำเรื่องเกี่ยวกับโทรศัพท์อยู่
เนาะ
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะครูไม่ยากใช่ไหม
ผม
คือผมเนี่ยนะครับ
อายุนะครับ
อายุเนี่ย
มันมีปัญหากับเทคโนโลยีครับ
[เพลง]
คุณเรียมเนี่ยเข้าใจเทคโนโลยีแต่ผมเนี่ย
อยู่กับ
หนังสือครับอยู่กับหนังสือนะครับไม่ได้
อยู่ไม่ได้อยู่กับเทคโนโลยีนะครับ
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้ผมก็ไปซื้อโทรศัพท์ใหม่
นะครับไปซื้อโทรศัพท์ Samsung นะครับก็
เลยคิดโอ้โหมันอะไร
สมองดีกว่าเรานะครับ
ตอนแรกเรียนก็คิดอยู่นะว่าผมต้องซื้อ
โทรศัพท์ใหม่เลยหรอแต่ว่าก็ซื้อใหม่ก็
โอเคดีเหมือนกันเพราะว่าครูโฮมก็บอกว่า
ใช้มานานมากแล้วครับ
ประมาณบอกเลยว่า 7 ปีหรือเปล่า 7  8 ปี
ครับ
ไม่คิดจะทำเทคโนโลยีคิดหนังสือ
คิดหนังสืออย่างเดียวนะครับแต่ว่าตอนนี้
ครูโฮมก็อยู่ใน Zoom กับเราทุกๆคนแล้วนะ
คะทุกคนก็เห็นครูโฮมผ่านวิดีโอเรียบร้อย
แล้ววันนี้เห็นใส่เสื้อสีชมพูครับ
สักครู่ไปเปลี่ยนเสื้อครับกลัวกลัว
โทรศัพท์แล้วก็ร้อนมากเพราะว่าอยู่กับ
เทคโนโลยีแล้วก็กลัวกลัวครูเรียมด้วยกลัว
ว่าครูเรียมจะแต่ว่าครูเรียมนี่ใจใจเย็น
มาก
ขอบคุณครับขอบคุณครับให้กำลังใจ
ครับขอบคุณครับ
ตอนนี้ครูโฮมก็สามารถเปิดไมค์เปิดกล้อง
เห็นรูปภาพเห็นวีดีโอได้เรียบร้อยแล้ว
เห็นทุกอย่างได้ขอบคุณคุณเรียมขอบคุณเอ่อ
จริงๆผมตื่นเต้นไหมเพราะว่าผมเมื่อก่อนผม
ใช้คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็มีลิงค์มาผมกดซูม
โอเคแต่ตอนนี้
คุณเรียมส่ง password มาดูนะครับ
อันนี้ Password  Code
44  53 แล้วก็อันนี้เป็นจอยนะครับผมไม่
เคยทำครับ
บอกกับผมคุณโจคุณโจรคุณโจนาธานบอกว่า
ผมเชื่อใจกูโฮมว่าครูโฮมทำได้แล้วไม่ต้อง
กลัวผมขอบคุณครับอันนี้ก็ขอบคุณนะครับ
กำลังใจดีมาก
8 ปีที่แล้วมีปัญหา
ผมก็เซ็ตกับครูเรียมเสร็จแล้วผมขับรถไป
ที่เซ็นทรัลบางนา
ภาษาไทยเซ็นทรัล
ภาษาอังกฤษ
ก่อนหน้านี้เหงื่อไหล
เหงื่อไหลมันก็ร้อนหรือเปล่า
จริงๆผม
ใจผมเนี่ย
คือจริงๆผมใจร้อน
ยากทำอะไรให้เสร็จเร็วๆ
นะครับ
แต่
ไม่ได้ครูเรียมบอกใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆ
ใจเย็นๆค่ะ
100 องศาเซลเซียส
นะครับ
ยืมยืมใจครูโฮมมาทำกับข้าวได้ไหม
ครับ
เราอาจจะเจอกันก่อนหน้านี้ก็ได้นะ
เจอครั้งแรกอยู่ที่ซูมออนไลน์
ขอบคุณมากคือความจำเลียมได้
จำได้ครับซูมออนไลน์นะครับครั้งที่ 2
เมื่อวานนี้
เมื่อวานเมื่อวานที่ได้คุยคุยกัน
นะครับแล้วก็วันนี้
ได้เปิดเปิดกล้องแล้วก็ได้คุยกันนะครับ
คือผมผมยังไม่เคยทำ
ซูมออนไลน์ที่สำหรับเรคคอร์ดตัวนี้นะครับ
ส่วนมากจะทำแล้วก็มีนักเรียน
นะครับ
อันนี้ก็แบบคุยกับระเบียงแค่ 2 คน
ครั้งแรก
เป็นครั้งแรก
หลายๆคนหลายๆคนรู้จักครูโฮมมาก่อนหน้านี้
แล้ว
เราก็อาจจะมีหลายๆคนแหละที่เพิ่งจะเคยดู
วีดีโอในช่องนี้แล้วก็ได้เจอครูโฮม
ครูแนะนำตัวเพิ่มอีกนิดนึงได้ไหมคะคือผม
เมื่อก่อนเป็น
ครูนะครับครู
ครู
นะครับเป็นครูเนี่ยตั้งแต่อายุ 22
ปี
ก็คือ 1  9  8  9
จนถึง
2  0  2  3 ก็คือตอนนี้
แต่ว่าเมื่อก่อนเป็นครูที่เอua
อเมริกา
ในความคิดนี่ก็แบบนานมากกว่าอายุเรียมอีก
แต่ก็คิดอยู่พูดออกไปดีไหมแต่ก็พูดแล้ว
ไม่เป็นไรครับ
เป็นครูนะครับเป็นครูสอนภาษาไทย
นะครับ
เป็นครูจริงๆนะครูเรียม
มีครูไม่จริงด้วยหรอคะ
คือเป็นครูที่ได้รับใบประกาศจาก
กระทรวงศึกษาธิการ
ที่ได้รับแล้ว
เราก็มีประสบการณ์สอนเรา
หาได้ไปเป็นครู
นะครับ
2538 อันนี้เป็นพ.ศ
ถ้าเป็นค.ศ
ใช่ไหม
ก็เป็นอันนี้เหลือเท่าไหร่
4 เหลือ 9 ใช่ไหม
9  9  5
นะครับ 1  9  9  5 ก็เป็นครู
นะครับ
นาน
เป็นครูแล้วเรียน
นักเรียนส่วนใหญ่ที่ครูโฮมเจอเนี่ยเป็น
นักเรียนที่มาจากไหน
1990 อเมริกา
อเมริกา
100% เลยหรือเปล่าคะ
อเมริกาประมาณ 70%
นะครับ
แล้ว 1995 มีอะไรที่แสบตา
สวีเดน
สระ
สวีเดน 80%
ไม่รู้ทำไม
เรียนภาษาไทย
สวีเดนชอบคนไทยสวีเดนชอบ
ประเทศไทย
ใครเป็นคนสวีเดนคะกำลังดูวิดีโอนี้อยู่
แล้วก็
1997 อันนี้ญี่ปุ่นครับ
ญี่ปุ่นครับ
แปลกมากเลยทำไมแบบในห้องเรียน
40 คนนะครับมีญี่ปุ่น 30 คน
เยอะ
มากเยอะครับ
ทำไมคะคนญี่ปุ่นมาเรียนพร้อมกับสวีเดนไม่
ได้หรอ
ครับอย่าง 1990
อเมริกาประเทศสหรัฐอเมริกา
1995 อันนี้สวีเดน
1996  1997 ญี่ปุ่น
นะครับ
แล้วก็ปี
1  9  9  8 ถึง 2  0  0  3 อันนี้ก็จะ
เป็นสะสม
หลายๆประเทศ
หลายๆประเทศมียุโรปออสเตรเลีย
สหรัฐอเมริกา
นะครับมีหมดนะครับ
ไม่เคยมีนักเรียนคนไทยเลยใช่ไหมคะ
คนไทยมีลูกครึ่ง
[เพลง]
ไทยอเมริกาไทยอังกฤษไทยจีน
แต่แบบไทย 100% ไม่มีเนาะเพราะว่าเขาพูด
ได้เยอะมาก
แล้วเขาพูดภาษาอังกฤษเก่งกว่าภาษาไทย
พูดภาษาไทยไม่ได้ครับ
ตอนนั้นนักเรียน 1 คนเนี่ยต้องเจอกับครู
นานไหมคะ
ถึงจะพูดได้
คืออย่างนี้
1  1  9  9
1989 จะเป็น n  a
แล้วก็เป็น SA
โทษครับมองไม่เห็น
อะไรคือ SA ค่ะ
เสียง
อันนี้เป็น Natural ภาษาอังกฤษขอโทษครับ
อันนี้เป็น
[เพลง]
แกรมม่า
อันนี้เป็น
ฝั่งเป็นธรรมชาติ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับอ๋อสวัสดี
ครับสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ผู้หญิงสวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับผู้ชาย
แต่ถ้าเป็น SA เป็น Structure  Approach
ก็คือจะมี
B1  B2
B3 แล้วก็ b  w
B1 เป็น Book  One  Book  Show  Book  3
สวัสดีสวัสดี
ครูก็ต้องพูดภาษาไทยชัด
สำคัญมากค่ะ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีครับ
นะครับต้องมีเสียงดัง
เสียงเบาๆไม่ได้เหรอคะ
ครูที่ออกเสียงเพราะว่า
การฟัง
ต้องดูปาก
ใช่
หนึ่ง
เจ็ด
แปด
เก้า
ไม่เหมือนกันนะครับ
ถ้าเกิดขยับปากได้เหมือนครูก็จะออกเสียง
ได้ชัดขึ้น
1  2
เคยเคยมีที่เรียนแบบออกไปพูดข้างนอกออกไป
ถ่ายวีดีโอข้างนอกช่วงโควิดเรียมใส่แมส
สามเหลี่ยมก็พูดนักเรียนก็แบบ
ครูเวลาถ่ายวีดีโอถอดแมสดีกว่ามองไม่เห็น
ปาก
เรียมก็เลยแบบทำไมอ่ะทำไมต้องเห็นปากด้วย
แค่ฟัง
ก็พอแล้ว
ตอนโควิดครับฟันบ๊ายบายไม่ได้ใส่พลาสติก
เพราะว่าไม่ชอบก็เลยให้มันเป็น
ธรรมชาติแบบ
ครับ
คือครูเรียมครับครูภาษาไทย
ปากต้องใช้เยอะครับ
ภาษาอื่นก็ใช้นะ
เราจะใช้อย่างเช่นผมจะอธิบายให้ฟังนะครับ
อย่างเช่นคำว่าปลาตัว
อันนี้ปลาขอโทษนะครับวาดรูปนิดนึงอ่ะปลา
เราคนไทยเนี่ยจะออกเสียงป่าเป็นอย่าง
นี้เราเราลืม
ตัวเปรอะตัวนี้ปลา
ปลา
ไม่ใช่ครับปลา
คือบางทีคนอเมริกาคนยุโรปเวลาฟังเอ้ยทำไม
คนไทยพูดไม่ชัด
ต้องพูดให้ชัด
นะครับถ้าพูดชัดแล้ว
มันมันจะเก่ง
นะครับ
อย่างอีกคำหนึ่งคำว่าไกล
กรุงเทพฯอเมริกากลาง
ใช่ไหมครับไกล
ไกล
ครับไกล
กรุงเทพอเมริกาไกล
ใช่
กรุงเทพฯอเมริกา
ไกลมากไกล
นะครับ
เวลาพูดเนี่ยเหมือนฝรั่งเวลาเขาฝรั่ง Yes
ครับ
คนไทยกินน้ำปลา
แล้วแต่ฝรั่งเขาบอกว่าคนไทยพูดจริงๆก็
พูดไม่ชัดนะ
ก็พูดไม่ชัดบ้างได้ไหมจะได้เหมือนคนไทย
อย่างนี้ค่ะผู้เรียน
คนไทยพูดไม่ชัดแต่ถ้านักเรียนคนอเมริกาคน
ยุโรปคนเอเชียคนไม่ใช่คนไทยแล้วพูดชัดมัน
มีเสน่ห์ครับน่ารัก
คนเห็นคนก็บอกอุ๊ยใครเป็นครู
เรียนกับใคร
ใครเป็นครูอ๋อเรียนกับครูเรียมอู้ยครู
เรียม
สอนดีมากนักเรียนพูดชัดมากนักเรียนของครู
โฮม
เรียนภาษาไทยได้เก่งมากพูดเก่งมาก
ทำไมนักเรียนโกรธมากวันนี้นักเรียนบอก
อยู่ที่ไหนมาๆๆผมอยากเรียนกับครู
ตอนนี้ครูขับแท็กซี่ครับ
ก็ไปรับจ๊อบอีกที่นึงแล้วก็มาเป็นครูด้วย
ขับแท็กซี่ครับบางทีบางทีมีนักเรียน
มาผมจะไปสุวรรณภูมิโอเคไหมผมบอกโอเคๆกี่
โมง
เออ 2 ทุ่มโอเคโอเค
เราต้องพูดภาษาไทยให้ชัด
ไม่ต้องอาย
เราจะอายอะไรคะธรรมดาก็ไม่อายอยู่แล้วนะ
ไม่บางทีฝรั่งบอกอาหารไทยอร่อยมากคนใช้
บอกอุ๊ยทำไมพูดภาษาไทยดีมากอายนะเป็นคน
ไทยแต่พูดภาษาไทยไม่ชัดฝรั่งพูดภาษาไทย
ชัดกว่า
คนไทยอายคนไทยรู้สึกว่าโอ้โห
พูดชัดกว่าฉันอีก
ใช่ครับ
แต่ก็ก็เป็นครูก็เป็นครูไปทั้งสอนพูดฟัง
เขียน
อ่าน
นะครับก็
ทำๆๆ
หลายๆอย่างนะครับ
แต่วันนี้ก็ครั้งแรกนะครับที่ได้มาสอนกับ
ครูเหลี่ยม
ดีมากเลยยังคิดว่าจะต้องได้เรียนรู้อะไร
อีกหลายๆอย่างจากครู
เรียมก็เป็นครูไม่ว่าจะสอนผมเรื่อง
เทคโนโลยีไม่ว่าจะสอนแต่ครูเรียมมีคำถาม
ดีครับ
นะครับมีคำถามดีคือผมปกตินะครับทุกๆวันๆ
เนี่ยคือ
ถ้าไม่มีคนถามผมก็ไม่พูด
ไม่รู้จะพูดอะไร
เรียนเป็นคนที่มีคำถามแล้วก็รอฟังอย่าง
เดียว
คือ
บางครั้งเนี่ยคนไทยกับฝรั่งกับคนยุโรป
อเมริกาเอเชียก็ต้องถาม
นะครับ
นะฮะบางคนใช้โทรศัพท์
ก็ไม่ได้ถาม
นะครับบางคนก็บอกสวัสดีครับเราเข้าใจแล้ว
ออกเสียงมาจากประเทศอะไร
นะครับ
ถ้าเป็นคนถ้าเป็นฝรั่งจะบอกสวัสดีครับ
ไปสุขุมวิทครับนี่ฝรั่ง
แต่ถ้าเป็นคนญี่ปุ่นก็จะบอก
[เพลง]
สวัสดีครับ
ผมบอกได้ครับ
แต่ถ้าได้มาเรียนกับครูโฮมก็จะพูดภาษาไทย
ได้แบบคนไทยแบบชัดมากกว่าคนใช้ไปอีกครับ
คือผมเนี่ยถ้ามีอย่างกูเรียมถามผมให้ผม
พูดอะไร
แล้วก็มีอะไรก็ตอบได้นะครับไม่ว่าจะเป็น
เรื่องทั่วไปเรื่องอะไรก็ได้นะครับแต่ไม่
เอาเรื่องดื่มเหล้านะเพราะว่าผมไม่ดื่ม
เหล้าไม่เอาเรื่องสูบบุหรี่นะผมไม่สูบ
บุหรี่ไม่เอาเรื่องคาราโอเกะอะไรอะไรผม
ไม่ร้องผมไม่ไปนะครับผมผมขับแท็กซี่ไปทุก
วันอยู่แล้วแต่ทำงานครับนะครับเอาเรื่อง
ที่นักเรียนอยากฟังภาษาไทย
เดี๋ยวเราก็จะมี
ครับผมหลายๆเรื่องที่จะคุยกันแน่นอนเลย
แต่ว่าวันนี้ได้หมดแล้วค่ะโอ้โห
ขอโทษนะครับทำไมกำลังสรุปเอาไว้
เมื่อไหร่
นะครับสำหรับวันนี้ขอรับใช่ค่ะสำหรับวัน
นี้ต้องลาไปก่อนแต่ถ้าชอบคลิปนี้อย่าลืม
กดไลค์นะคะ
ฝากกดไลค์กด Subscribe กดไลค์กดแชร์กดติด
ตามนะครับใช่แล้วค่ะวันนี้เรียนกับครูโฮม
ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณ
ครับสวัสดีครับสวัสดี